depression is said to be the leading
cause of disability worldwide and today
we're going to talk about two treatments
available to some people who are
suffering depression i'm joined by ben
spielberg and judith
from tns and brain health thank you both
for being here going to talk about
tms it's also called transcranial
magnetic stimulation and also a drug
called ketamine let's start with tms
first of all this is fascinating this is
a treatment it's not a drug but rather a
way to stimulate the brain
tell us how that works and what kind of
things you've seen from it so tms is a
transcranial magnetic stimulation as you
stated it's a new treatment that is used
to treat
symptoms of depression especially the
non-resistant
depression people who've tried
different kinds of medications and it
has not worked for them or people who
are on medications like antidepressants
and it's worked somehow but they're
seeing side effects or they still want
to continue taking their medications but
they want to try alternative routes to
um alleviate their depression symptoms
yeah and then the idea behind this is
that it stimulates the brain or the part
of the brain that's inactive during
depression right correct correct yeah so
we we tend to think of depression as
this serotonin
deficiency or neurotransmitter imbalance
but uh research over the past couple
decades has shown that's not really the
case and that's not really what's
happening in the brain what's really
happening is that people with depression
have specific parts of the brain that
are under active so there's less
cellular metabolism less blood flow and
what tms can do is it emits this
it emits these magnetic waves that
actually turn this part of the brain
back on so as they come in and do more
and more sessions there's more blood
flow more metabolism and thus more
neuroplasticity in these areas fda
approved and i was searching online and
found a lot of people who truly believe
this has helped them less as we don't
have much time and i wish we had more
talk about ketamine which is a drug
that originally was an anesthesia for
animals judith and now it is being used
uh to treat depression on for people
yeah so they found out like micro dosing
of ketamine is being used actually to
treat like
depression anxiety ptsd so some people
like if they're going through a divorce
or they're going through a hard time and
they just need a little bit of help
ketamine would be the ideal um drug to
use and it's more effective faster than
actually being on an antidepressant then
you know it's it's it's
it's
it takes a little bit of
it's not a cumulative effect as much as
it is it works right away is it right
right
yeah even though we it's actually even
though it's still accumulated because we
do like a packet of eight doses okay so
they come two weeks two days per week
until they finish their eight doses so
it's more accumulative in your system
but their symptoms are relieved like
immediately it's fascinating i wish we
had so much more time to talk about this
judith and ben thank you so much for
being here today to talk about this and
we want to thank uh brain tms and brain
health las vegas for sponsoring this
segment if you'd like more information
there's the number on your screen 833
tms today or the website is
com tmsbrainhealth.com be back